[Music]
in 1998
whilst working abroad in germany dr
christian schaefer received a strange
gift from fellow academic
it was a small book about 100 pages and
had ornate green cover
according to a colleague it was thought
to be written between 1760 and 1780
when she looked inside she was surprised
to see that the neat handwriting pages
were in a completely unintelligible
script
although i had some familiar letters
from the roman alphabet the text also
features greek lettering
and some unique symbols never seen
anywhere else
it was clear that the book was a cipher
an encrypted code designed to hide a
secret message
the only words she could read were found
on the inside cover philip
1866 and at the end copiales
iii latin word relates to our word for
code
the book came to be known as the
copialis cipher
for 250 years its message remained
unknown
until 2011. we now know what it says
here's how it's done
uppsala sweden 13 years later
a guest speaker from the university of
southern california was visiting dr
schaefer's university
his name was professor kevin knight he
was a specialist in machine translation
and had previously created algorithms to
automatically translate one language
into another
similar to systems like google translate
he had previously built a program that
could translate dante's inferno
based on the user's choice of meter and
rhyme scheme but he's no cryptographer
despite this schaefer approached knight
with a book and the two began to discuss
it
along with schaefer's colleague
globsilla berta megyesi the team soon
began to establish that the book was
indeed authentic and not a hoax
they handed the cipher to professor
knight to take back to california
and with this the work begun being a
computer scientist
knight transcribed the entire document
onto a computer so it could be machine
readable
he found 88 unique symbols and gave each
one a code
this symbol became lip this one oh and
this one
said s so now with the press for button
the text went from this
to this but the cipher still made no
sense
but at least it was legible for his
computer this would allow to work
quickly
able to efficiently run scans to figure
out any patterns or future translations
knight first looked to the roman letters
scattered across the page
he believed that if he isolated them
from the rest of the symbols the message
would reveal itself
in this theory all other symbols were
nulls meaningless characters meant to
throw off any cryptographers
isolating the roman letters did not seem
to reveal much at first
they were scrambled and did not appear
to have any meaning
he ran the roman lettering through his
databases of languages to see if any
linguistic patterns emerged within the
book
nothing the attempt was failure and the
cipher was still a mystery
back to square one including all the
letters this time he ran a computer scan
to see whether any letter combinations
repeat themselves in the document
this is a smart way to figure out
certain letters as some letters only
ever appear in pairs
for example in english the letter q is
almost always followed by you
quit question queen square acquiesce
words like sadiq and fakir are of the
very few exceptions and are usually
imported words from other languages
if he could find unique letter pairs it
would allow him to decipher his very
first letters
he ran a scan and this time found 10
unique character combinations in the
text
progress it seemed that the vowels or
circumflexes were frequently followed by
a z symbol or a pi symbol
this symbol was often followed by this
one in some cases
this pair had a third letter form at the
end this three-letter pattern would
allow professor knight to make his first
breakthrough
knight already had reason to suspect
that the original language of the
document was in german
first the book was originally located in
germany and second is the inscription
philip 1866 which uses the german double
p spelling of the name
knight notice that in german c was
almost always followed by an
h and so on
moreover a ch is usually followed by
t
so he suspected that the mysterious
three-letter pattern was
cht he didn't realize it yet
but he was right there are 26 letters in
the alphabet
but 88 letters in the copied cipher
knight theorized that multiple symbols
must have stood for a single german
letter
he played around a bit with the
characters and soon discovered that
these three symbols
all stood for i it seemed to work
and soon he started to assemble small
words and sentences
this became dare this became candidate
this became antwerped their candidate
and fought it
the candidate answers
with this breakthrough knight continued
to work on the code and steadily began
to decipher more and more letters and
quirks
the circumflexed vowels all stood for e
this cross symbol stood for sch and the
colons doubled the previous letter
soon knight was able to build an entire
alphabet
since he already transcribed a digital
version at the start
all he needed to do was run the alphabet
through his document and
success before him lair texts that no
one had been able to read for 250 years
he was right the text was in german
well lay before professor knight and
soon dr schaefer and dr mcgissi
was a series of rituals that described
the initiation of the candidate into a
secret group
the text is older than they thought
originally believed to be written
between 1760 and 1780
it was more likely written between
1730-1740
here's the first page of the copialis
cipher there are some large
non-letter symbols yet to be decoded the
team believe that they stand in for
actual names of people
and roles within the organization and
cannot be decoded any further
first law book
secret part first section secret
teachings for apprentices
first title initiation right
if the safety of the is guaranteed
and the is opened by the chief by
putting on his hat
the candidate is fetched from another
room by the younger doorman
and by the hand is led in and to the
table of the chief
who asks him first if he desires to
become
secondly if he submits to the rules of
the
and without rebelliousness suffer
through the time of apprenticeship
thirdly be silent
and furthermore be willing to offer
himself a volunteer
in the most committed way the candidate
answers yes
the book continues on like this
describing complex initiation procedures
and rituals
except that is for the end the
concluding pages offer a political
commentary
describing the natural rights of man and
talks about self-evident truths that man
is born free
similar language to the american
declaration of independence
some 30 to 40 years after this document
was produced
making this document one of the earliest
to be espousing these sorts of ideas
but who were the authors of the document
it's never made clear in the cipher
but there are some clues first this
symbol
that appears throughout the book it was
believed to be a lip by night
but after studying it schaefer believed
it to be an eye
then came the recurring phrase the light
hand
this was a phrase used by german secret
society
known as the a name derived from the
latin word oculus
meaning i officially known as the great
enlightened society of oculus
they were based in the german town of
wolfenbutel
on the outskirts of hanover they were a
group of academics and surgeons who
performed early forms of eye surgery
and can be recognized by their insignia
featuring an
eye they were seen as being highly
protective and secretive
and only admitted the most respected
surgeons into their organization
this is their public image at least the
existence of a deeply complex encoded
cipher
implies that there is more to them than
just eye surgery
but that we just do not know
the cypher doesn't have any more
information so why the rituals
why the political commentary at the end
what happened to the group
we know very little more about the
oculus and the copialist cipher might be
the best look into this group we have
we do know that around the time of the
document's production in 1738
pope clement xii forbade all catholics
from joining a larger
more notable secret society the
freemasons
many saw the freemasons as a secret
homosexual cult
or political insurgent group others
rumored that they worship the devil
whatever happened the oculus were forced
underground
and the secrets went with them 250 years
later
and our little book emerges
but let's not forget the genius that
went behind cracking the copialis cipher
naturally i've oversimplified it a bit
so i've included links below that show
professor knight and his team's process
with published papers and articles as
well as links to the full document
itself
since the copialis decipherment knight
has used his expertise to approach other
cryptic texts
including the zodiac killer cipher and
perhaps the most enigmatic document of
all time
the voynich manuscript to this day both
remain to be deciphered
even by professor knight but that's the
story for another day
goodbye
hey thank you for the end of this video
i hope you enjoyed so the channel had a
spike in views and subscribers since the
last video
it may be a modest increase compared
with larger channels but to me it means
the world and pushes me to make more
content
so if you like the video and want to see
more like comment
maybe share with a friend but most of
all subscribe to ho chi lago